vamos a resolver el siguiente ejercicio
que es muy bonito dice juan y sara se
suben a una rueda de la fortuna en
chapultepec en la ciudad de mexico la
rueda tiene 16 metros de diámetro
entonces vamos pintando nuestro problema
ahí tienen ustedes nuestra
rueda de la fortuna
espero que pueda pintarlo bien
más o menos vamos a corregirlo un poco
son menos tienen ahí ustedes
la rueda de la fortuna muy bien más o
menos digo no es la mejor rueda de la
fortuna que pude haber hecho pero para
fines prácticos está nos va a servir
entonces ahí tienen la rueda de la
fortuna y nos dice que tiene 16 metros
de diámetro entonces si nos fijamos en
su centro ahí está su centro quiere
decir que cualquier radio tiene de
longitud 8 metros 8 metros muy bien
además nos dice que la rueda de la
fortuna gira a tres revoluciones por
minuto
esto gira a tres revoluciones por minuto
muy bien entonces cada minuto da tres
vueltas esta rueda de la fortuna y su
punto más bajo está a un metro del suelo
entonces nos vamos a su punto más bajo
que es este y nos dice que está a un
metro del suelo
un metro del suelo
un metro del suelo muy bien aquí ya está
el sol
déjenme terminar de leerles el problema
dice supongamos que la altura que vamos
a denotar con h donde se encuentran en
la rueda de la fortuna es una función
senoidal del tiempo donde te iguala 0
representa el punto más bajo en la rueda
entonces nos dice que aquí de igual a 0
es el punto más bajo y que la altura por
ejemplo si se encuentran aquí la altura
respecto al suelo me imagino es este una
función senoidal hay que escribir una
función para h muy bien entonces hay
mucho jugó que sacarle a este problema
primero vamos a ver qué significan tres
revoluciones por minuto muy bien dice si
son tres revoluciones por minuto y el
tiempo lo vamos a dar en segundos
entonces tenemos tres revoluciones tres
revoluciones cada 60 segundos verdad
entonces que son tres revoluciones cada
60 segundos dividimos entre tres arriba
y abajo y nos queda una revolución es
decir una vuelta cada
20 segundos muy bien entonces pero una
revolución son 360 grados están de
acuerdo es una vuelta entonces estas son
360 grados cada 20 segundos y podemos
efectuar esta división porque 360 entre
20 es lo mismo que 36 entre 2 que son 18
grados cada segundo muy bien entonces
esto es más o menos cómo se mueve
nuestra rueda de la fortuna y vamos a
empezar a hacer manipulación en este
dibujo para poder determinar cómo es h
por ejemplo vamos a suponer que nuestros
nuestros amigos se encuentran en este
punto de la rueda de la fortuna muy bien
entonces nos fijamos en la línea que
conecta al centro con este punto de aquí
muy bien entonces fijémonos ahora
también en por ejemplo esta altura de
aquí del centro al punto más bajo
esta esta altura son 8 metros pero si
además le agregamos el metro que tenemos
digamos de distancia al suelo entonces
hasta aquí digamos hasta este punto h es
igual a 9 metros muy bien digamos no no
le va a poner h le voy a poner otra
letra
de esta distancia de del suelo al centro
son 9 metros muy bien entonces vamos a
construir un triángulo rectángulo aquí
porque nos fijamos ahora en esta línea
en esta línea y entonces bueno
rellenamos este triángulo este triángulo
rectángulo verdad justo por cómo lo
construí y entonces tenemos aquí este
ángulo por ejemplo de aquí cuánto cuánto
mide este ángulo bueno pensemos que aquí
empezaron nuestros amigos en la rueda de
la fortuna y después de cierta ciertas
unidades de tiempo digamos después de
tres segundos se encuentran ahora acá
muy bien en este punto quiere decir que
como cada segundo dieron tiraron 18
grados esto de aquí mide 18 grados por
el tiempo que recorrieron verdad si
pasaron tres segundos este tendrá tres
por 18 y así sucesivamente muy bien
entonces con toda esta información
nosotros ya podemos obtener cómo es h y
pensemos en lo siguiente
esta es digamos la altura déjenme
pintarlo así la altura la altura esta
altura es la que nos interesa esta
altura que si nos fijamos es lo mismo
que esta altura esta misma altura es la
misma verdad
esta es la h que queremos encontrar
entonces vamos a ver cuánto mide esto
bueno esto no no sabemos cuánto mide
pero lo que sí sabemos es esta línea
azul por qué porque la línea azul es un
radio de este círculo y dijimos que el
radio cualquier radio mide 8 metros
ahora bien está esta altura de este
triángulo también podemos determinarlo
porque fíjense muy bien que la altura
completa era de 9 metros pero hasta aquí
hasta digamos el pie
en este vértice del triángulo mide h
entonces tenemos 9 y esto es 9
restándole h así que esto mide 9 menos h
entonces fíjate muy bien que tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo tenemos un ángulo y
tenemos un cateto y la hipotenusa
entonces hay que ver este cateto de aquí
es el adyacente a este ángulo de 18
grados
así que hay que pensar que función
trigonométricas me relaciona cateto
adyacente con hipotenusa muy bien y
realmente eso es muy fácil porque es el
cose no es verdad entonces tenemos
coseno de 18 te debe ser igual al cateto
cateto adyacente que son 9 menos h entre
8 y ya ahora lo único que tenemos que
hacer es ir despejando multiplicamos de
ambos lados por 8 y nos queda 8 coseno
de 18 te debe ser igual a 9 - h muy bien
si ahora restamos 9 de ambos lados
tenemos menos 9 + 8 coseno de 18 t igual
a menos h y si ahora multiplicamos por
menos 1 como nos queda h h es igual si
multiplicamos por menos uno es 9 menos 8
coseno de 18 t muy bien entonces aquí
está nuestra fórmula que nos piden
aquí está ya en la fórmula en términos
del tiempo y en el siguiente vídeo lo
que voy a hacer es graficar esta función
así que nos vemos muy pronto